while the finished Barbie movie might
have been Kenneth for some fans there
were some planned moments that didn't
come together in the film smooches
cameos and a weird romance here's what
was cut from Barbie Barbie as a movie is
a lot in the very best way in just under
two hours we watch his characters
experience everything from
disenfranchisement to dream ballet to
existential crises it might surprise you
then that some things actually got cut
from Greta gerwig's latest film some of
which makes sense and some of which are
a total bummer various potential Kens
played by Ben Platt Bowen Yang and
others were in the running to appear
alongside main Ken Ryan Gosling but
couldn't commit to spending three months
in London Jonathan Groff missed out on
playing Allen for the same reason Emma
Mackey from sex education appears in the
finished film as physicist Barbie but a
joke about her resemblance to Star
Margot Robbie was cut when it simply
turned out that the two didn't look all
that much alike with different hair
colors so what did we miss out on in
Barbie when all was said and done
perhaps the most heartbreaking thing cut
from Barbie is a cameo from Saoirse
Ronan and Timothy chalamet both of whom
have worked with Gerwig on her other two
films Ronan LED both ladybird and Little
Women as Christine Lady Bird McPherson
and Joe March and chalamet had a
supporting role in lady bird as Kyle
scheibel and a larger turn as Theodore
Laurie Lawrence in both movies the two
play Love interests and they clearly
work well together and with Gerwig but
according to the director the timing
just didn't work out as Gerwig told
Cinema Blend well it was always going to
have to be a sort of smaller thing
because Ronan was actually producing at
the time which I am so proud of her for
and of course it's brilliant but it was
going to be a specialty Cameo Ronan is
producing a film called the outrun in
which she'll also star so what about
chalamet Gerwig revealed I was also
going to do a specialty Cameo with Timmy
and both of them couldn't do it and I
was so annoyed but I love them so much
chalamet has been working on a ton of
projects lately including Dune 2 and
Wonka so this isn't a complete shock but
it is a disappointment a constant
through line throughout Barbie is that
Ken is hopelessly in love with Barbie
who just doesn't fully reciprocate his
feelings sure there as Ken puts it
boyfriend girlfriend but Barbie never
wants Ken to be at her house because
it's always girls night beyond that they
don't even kiss Ken leans in and kisses
the air near Barbie's face and then
tells her how wonderful the non-kiss was
before asking if he can spend the night
I thought I might stay over tonight why
because we're a girlfriend boyfriend you
do what
I'm actually not sure during an
interview alongside Robbie with people
Gosling said that the actors and
creatives working on Barbie tried to
figure out how Ken and Barbie would even
successfully kiss but it was just way
too weird Gosling said it was so funny
trying to figure out what their idea of
kissing might be I'm so glad all of that
got cut out the scenes between Barbie
and Ken are funny enough so missing out
on a really weird kiss seems fine losing
an appearance by serci Ronan and Timothy
chalamet is one thing losing a scene
between Ken and weird Barbie is another
matter altogether Mashable revealed that
there's a behind-the-scenes photo of
Gerwig in action and sitting in the
director's chair laughing as weird
Barbie sits on the Barbie land pool
while cradling Ken's head in her lap so
what happened to the scene exactly weird
Barbie even directly tells Robbie's
Barbie that she's got a thing for Ken
saying she'd love to see whatever nude
blob he's packing under those jeans Kate
McKinnon is one of the funniest actors
around and she and Gosling have worked
together several times during her tenure
on Saturday Night Live a bizarre romance
between Ken and weird Barbie could have
been a delightful little aside during
Barbie especially when you consider that
our main Barbie really doesn't have any
interest in him perhaps if Ken and weird
Barbie had shared a moment together he
could have finally learned whatever
Barbies and Ken's do during sleepovers
Barbie is in theaters now
foreign